[Musica]
siamo abituati a pensare al volontariato
come qualcosa di sempre positivo oggi vi
mostro il suo lato oscuro e come
rimediare
quando venti anni partì per la mia prima
missione di volontariato in india
pagai una grande organizzazione
internazionale e fui mandato in questo
piccolo fano trofia nel sud del paese
lì incontrai un bambino di nome antoni
antoni era stato abbandonato dalla madre
a un padre disturbato mentalmente che
poi l'abusato in quei tre mesi io e
antoni ci siamo legati
quello che non sapevo da ventenne non
preparato non supervisionato è che una
volta finita questa missione il distacco
attraversato un secondo abbandono per il
bambino un secondo tra uomo e così fu
antoni le fu distrutto la domanda è
potremmo farlo qui insomma accetteremmo
mai un volontario indiano senza
qualifiche senza supervisione delle
nostre scuole con i nostri bambini
se la risposta è no perché noi possiamo
farlo
nel terzo mondo quando a vent'anni io
ero un volo in tour i st il volo in
turismo è un fenomeno che coinvolge
oltre 20 milioni di persone al mondo
ogni anno per un business di oltre 170
miliardi di euro
la parola nasce dalla commistione di
volontariato e turismo cosa significa
significa mettere al centro
dell'equazione il volontario anziche i
beneficiari anziché la comunità aiutata
il volontario con le sue esigenze con i
suoi desideri con la sua graphic
gratificazione qua vediamo quello che è
quella che è la spesa di una di queste
grandi associazioni internazionali di
volontarismo solo la parte gialla
finisce sul luogo viene donata al
linda natalini impiegata sul sul luogo
che si intende aiutare e non tutto
arriva all'associazione parte per il
viaggio
insomma gran parte dei soldi questi
volontari benintenzionati ma ingenui
versano all'organizzazione vengono
assorbiti dalla burocrazia esempi di
volontarismo sono la ragazza in tanzania
che costruisce una biblioteca di giorno
solo perché muratori locali di notte la
smantellino e la ricostruiscano come si
deve in silenzio
un altro esempio è il tour operator di
nuova delhi che per 50 euro ti permette
di andare in una baraccopoli scegliere
una famiglia povera lido piacimento e
dare loro il cibo come se fosse allo zoo
un altro esempio sono gli orfanotrofi in
cambogia pieni di finti orfani bambini
che hanno padre e madre ma sono tenuti
in condizioni di degrado per generare
compassione e ricevere i fondi
tutto questo si sostanzia in un concetto
chiamato pornografia della povertà il
che significa esasperare e privare
dell'umanità
queste comunità di modo da generare
compassione pietà e di nuovo fondi
denaro scusate sono un po emozionato
come invertiamo la rotta dopo aver
finito la mia prima missione di
volontariato in india sono tornato in
italia e ho deciso di mettere affronto a
frutto quelli che davvero i miei talenti
non insegnare non giocare con i bambini
ma a raccogliere fondi e sensibilizzare
e parlare con la gente
dopodiché ho deciso di trasferirmi in
india e di restare
sono stato in india per quattro anni non
per insegnare ma per imparare quest'anno
sono tornato l'anno scorso sono tornato
in europa è affondato
quest'anno fondato alla mia associazione
di volontariato che promuove anziché il
volontarismo il volontà lento cos'è il
volontà lento il volontà lento è la
commissione l'unione tra l'analisi dei
bisogni concreti dalla comunità che
vogliamo aiutare e una selezione attenta
delle competenze dei volontari c'è una
citazione molto bella di buckminster
fuller che dice parafrasata che è
inutile combattere la realtà esistente
quello che bisogna fare è inventare un
nuovo modello che renda il modello
esistente obsoleto
per fare questo abbiamo fondato masi
masi è il volontà lento concretizzato
masi è la prima scuola per bambini e
adolescenti rifugiati del campo profughi
di samos in grecia
la domanda è perché è perché è la
domanda principale del volontà lento
perché è fondare masi perché noi
crediamo nell'importanza di ripristinare
il diritto fondamentale all'istruzione
di questi bambini di bambini che hanno
sono fuggiti dalla guerra sono arrivati
in europa sperando in una vita migliore
si trovano imprigionati in un campo
profughi costruito per 700 persone in
cui le vivono ora 4.000 questi bambini
stanno anche per un anno nel campo
profughi vivono con le loro famiglie
a volte in tende a volte senza tende
quando non c'è non c'è
non c'è disponibilità attraverso
l'inverno senza scuola
questo è il punto principale quindi
quello che abbiamo fatto e abbiamo
abbiamo analizzato la situazione è
cercato di capire i bisogni reali di
queste persone e bisogni sono tre
istruzione formazione sicurezza e questo
noi cerchiamo di soddisfare i
destinatari sono sono i questi bambini
che se se non vengono aiutati avranno
già perduto loro passato perché la
guerra la migrazione gli abusi che
soffrono ora ma senza un intervento
perderanno anche il futuro questa è la
realtà
a meno che qualcuno faccia qualcosa come
vi dicevo gli obiettivi di masi che è
questa
sono tre numero uno l'istruzione
didattico masi e funzionerà con una
scuola normale come quella che abbiamo
qua a bologna nel resto dell'italia nel
resto dell'europa ovvero insegniamo
inglese greco storia matematica
geografia scienza educazione sessuale
civica arte musica insomma una scuola
normale
inoltre quello che noi però pensiamo sia
fondamentale è dare a questi bambini la
possibilità di sopravvivere e integrarsi
quindi e formativo
i nostri i nostri insegnanti insegnano
non solo queste materie che ho appena
elencato ma anche igiene mentale
intelligenza emotiva come gestire il
fallimento cosa semplice come come
gestire le finanze come gestire le
proprie interazioni interpersonali
quello che noi puntiamo ad ottenere è
l'autosufficienza dei nostri studenti
quello che pensiamo sia uno dei più
grandi crimini dell'aiuto umanitario
internazionale è che lucrano sulla
dipendenza delle persone che aiutano
ovviamente se non è più una clientela
non è più un recipiente il tuo business
ha finito per cui ed è nel tuo interesse
continuare a poter offrire questo
servizio
il nostro obiettivo è rendere questi
bambini questi ragazzi indipendenti 3 la
sicurezza masi non è semplicemente una
scuola o un posto in cui facciamo
mentoring è anche un posto in cui
offriamo un altro
nativa sicura agli abusi del campo ma si
è aperto dalle 8 di mattina alle 8 45 di
mattina fino a sera
i bambini possano restare lì a giocare a
riposare e a mangiare offriamo offriamo
cibo perché alcuni di questi bambini a
volte vanno a letto senza cena mano
letto affamati perché non c'è abbastanza
cibo per tutti nel campo ora come
possiamo fare questo il punto cardine
sono i nostri volontari
il punto è il volontà lento è che si
incentra sul sul talento e sull'abilità
della persona che selezioniamo quindi la
selezione è cardine
noi non diciamo ok hai del tempo da
spendere
quest'estate vieni e gioca con i bambini
no diciamo questo il nostro bisogno ai
questo talento per favore viene quindi
ne facciamo una selezione molto
scrupoloso chiediamo un coinvolgimento
minimo dai volontari perché è importante
ricordare che i problemi non sono mai la
povertà ola ola malattia sono sempre i
sistemi che le chele alimentano i
sistemi non si possono cambiare in un
mese e terzo prima ancora che i nostri
volontari possano interagire con i
bambini noi offriamo un training
intensivo di tre giorni per cui quando
il volontario arriva finalmente ad
interagire a lavorare veramente è
innanzitutto ben equipaggiato ed è
sicuro e ci possiamo fidare
ovviamente questo sistema di di
recruitment di selezione è piuttosto
esigente come si traduce nella
esperienza del volontario stesso è che
quando il volontario arriva perché ci
fidiamo di lui perché crediamo nella
seconda lita perché sappiamo che la
persona giusta per questo lavoro
il volontario riceve responsabilità
crediamo molto nella nella delega dei
poteri nella delega delle incombenze per
cui per esempio il volontario può
gestire la sua classe se un insegnante
la sua classe come meglio credi
impiegare i metodi di studio che
preferisce seguire il curriculum che
preferisce
e gestire gli studenti secondo la sua
creatività
in secondo luogo pensiamo che questo
crei un atmosfera in un ambiente di di
sicurezza di appartenenza per cui il
volontario si sente parte di un team e
non è non è semplicemente qui per la
perfetta la gratificazione o per le foto
di instagram
questo ovviamente questo questo sistema
di personale si traduce anche
nell'organizzazione il volontà lento si
riflette anche sulla gerarchia sulla
struttura per esempio noi presentiamo
una gerarchia completamente orizzontale
che significa noi non crediamo in una
gerarchia piramidale per cui quando
abbiamo un meeting il volontario
l'amministratore eppure gli studenti
attraverso rappresentanti votati possono
partecipare e votare hanno potere
decisionale e il mio voto è il tuo voto
e il loro voto allo stesso potere
questo è importante perché crediamo che
i beneficiari ovvero le persone che
aiutiamo abbiano il diritto e il potere
di avere di essere ascoltati il volontà
il volo in turismo crede o meglio ci
propina questa idea di volontari
occidentali che arrivano insegna non
importa se non siano qualificati se
siano dei liceali arrivano e insegnano
al terzo mondo perché sanno di più
mentre noi rifiutiamo questa concezione
e promuoviamo un idea per cui nessuno
nessuno potrà sapere conoscere meglio i
bisogni della comunità se non la
comunità stessa
infine perché il volontà lento richiede
impegno e sacrificio a volte c'è la
possibilità sempre per un volontario che
sia eccellente di essere assorbito
all'interno dell'organizzazione per cui
non essere volontario ma diventare in
parte dello staff questa porta è sempre
aperta per un
un volontario che sia meritevole per
esempio tutti noi lo staff della mia
associazione siamo tutti volontari
questo questo chiaramente crea un
ambiente di di appartenenza non solo al
progetto singolo per cui ai mesi in cui
il volontario opera ma alla causa al
movimento in conclusione io penso che
sia io credo fermamente che sia
necessario è molto importante educare i
volontari e le organizzazioni e le
associazioni a un volontariato etico sia
importantissimo cominciare a pensare ai
problemi non come il loro
ma come nostri perché noi siamo
appartenenti in alcuni casi allo stesso
avvicinato stessa città stesso paese
razza specie
penso che sia importante perché quando
comincia a pensare ai loro problemi come
nostri perché sono nostri
comincia ad imparare comincia a capire
che non siamo qua per aiutare ma siamo
qua per costruire insieme
e il bello dell'educazione e che non
dobbiamo aspettare il permesso di questo
o quel potente o la situazione perfetta
possiamo cominciare ora grazie
[Applauso]